bueno primero todo muchas gracias por
invitarme y bueno esta reacción se
explica por el deseo del presidente del
gobierno Pedro Sánchez de intentar
cambiar el marco no de la derrota del
partido socialista y sobre todo de sus
partidos a su izquierda y socios de
coalición a intentar volver a cambiar
uno algo que le favorezca no en el
sentido de Unión de la izquierda voto
hacia el peso es intentar de esta forma
cambiar el relato que le pueda
beneficiar sobre todo teniendo en cuenta
que estamos ante un momento de la
derecha en las que en lo que puede
conseguir digamos en los pseudos
tradicionales del psoe más votos no yo
creo que es la cuestión es esta no
intentar evitar ese desgaste de seis
meses más de gobierno porque recordemos
que las elecciones iban a ser en
diciembre y digamos reagrupar todo ese
voto que ha caído la extensión Incluso
en el psoe en el perdón en la extensión
o en el PP en el psoe no o incluso
intentar reactivar de esta forma su
electorado su progresista y Pablo ahora
hablaremos de la fragmentación con la
que puede llegar la izquierda a la
izquierda del psoe pero en primer lugar
a qué responde considera usted el auge
de la formación conservadora del partido
popular y de la de ultraderecha de vox
bueno la Yo diría que al final esas
elecciones autonómicas y locales han
tenido un marco nacional no en vez de
digamos analizar lo que ha pasado en
cada localidad o en cada autonomía se ha
hablado más de un plebiscito de cara al
gobierno de Pedro Sánchez No que al
final recordemos que lleva tiempo
gobernando llevo un desgaste a sufrir
las consecuencias de una pandemia de una
crisis energética y ahora mismo de la
inflación y de una guerra
luego yo creo que también hay una hay
una situación de hartazgo y de enfado
por ciertas expectativas que no se han
cumplido con el gobierno de coalición no
yo creo que esa suma de cuestiones
aparte de digamos que una derecha que a
lo mejor está más movilizada y genera
quizás más ilusión yo creo que han sido
los elementos que han propiciado esto
Esta debacle del psoide de sus socios y
un aumento del apoyo digamos en la
derecha y hablando de Los Socios no y de
esta coalición de gobierno que como
usted decía quizás no ha cumplido las
expectativas hablando de Los Socios de
unidas podemos que llega en una
situación un poco incierta dado su dada
su desaparición
a ciertas regiones en regiones tan
importantes como Madrid pero también el
hecho de que la vicepresidenta del
gobierno y una de las figuras mejores
valoradas de este ejecutivo la ministra
de trabajo Yolanda Díaz ha lanzado una
nueva plataforma sumar qué se espera que
pasen estos 10 días que tienen las
fuerzas políticas para presentar
coaliciones
bueno llevábamos meses viendo unos
choques bastante fuertes entre podemos y
sumar y sus distintos digamos socios Por
así decirlo porque su madre es una
plataforma que incluya varios partidos
no los que nos apodemos de momento la
cuestión es que parece que los
resultados y la adelanto electoral ha
apropiado que los partidos de podemos y
los que están englobados en sumar pues
quieran acercar posiciones No de hecho
hoy la secretaria general de podemos
Larra ha anunciado que estaban ya en
negociaciones con sumar para hacer lo
que todo el mundo de los ciudadanos
están progresistas Están buscando no esa
Unión del espacio político yo creo que
he visto los resultados que hemos tenido
las
ayer en las elecciones autonómicas y
locales Yo pienso que efectivamente van
a buscar un consenso y van a intentar
llegar juntos y intentar entablar la
mejor plataforma y candidatura con el
fin de no repetir una debacle continua
no que extremos lo que estamos viendo
últimamente en cada elección que hemos
visto